[Music]
Singapore is known for its incredible
cuisine and although the ultra-modern
city has high-end options its most
famous for its street food for
generations thousands of so-called
hawkers have been offering savory dishes
from their small stalls but now that's
under threat
Christina Ruffini has the story in
food-obsessed Singapore being a picky
eater isn't a character flaw it's a
national pastime Singaporeans are very
fussy like in the way like we all have
our own life I have my own favorite
chicken rice now I have my own favourite
hockey and in stores them and you can
debate all day long about wishes the bad
since you fight all about food you fight
about food big things you talk about
food and then we talk about what we're
gonna have next nowhere is that passion
more on display then if the city's
open-air food markets or hawker centres
where vendors spend decades perfecting
one or two distinct dishes from
sugarcane juice to steaming piles of
noodles all for just a few dollars a
plate
Hawker centers are so essentially
Singaporean almost every neighborhood
here has one Tiong Bahru is one of the
oldest and a favorite of locals Lily Lim
and stéphane Lo Green had insan favorite
star
I'm Singaporean Joe going to a hawker
centre
that's what she was saying in the US we
would never like go to the longest line
but here that's how to tell us and that
red circle in the window that's a fifth
Corman award from the famously finicky
and ferociously French Michelin Guide
it's a big deal for him to be able to
display that sticker
but despite the loyal fanbase of certain
stalls Hawker centers are losing
popularity especially with young people
who tend to prefer the glitzy upscale
restaurants of the central business
district and their central air
conditioning are you worried that the
next generation is not going to come
here I was I am I am KF Seetoh is a
heritage food expert and evangelist I
blame Instagram you know if it's not an
Instagram it doesn't exist the food may
not necessarily be photogenic but Seto
says Singapore will lose an essential
part of its culture if hawkers shudder
there stops this is a place where
Singapore comes to celebrate not just
food but Singaporean muscle you come
here at lunch it's packed with people
they don't care who you are
even our Prime Minister lines up
forcefully in an effort to help preserve
these places and possibly skip the line
the Prime Minister's government has
nominated hawker culture for the United
Nations list of the intangible cultural
heritage of humanity starting in 2008
the distinguished roster includes more
than 400 global traditions including
Indian yoga and Neapolitan pizza
twirling
but waiting popularity isn't the only
problem
so he has been selling it for 30 over
years this children have all grown up
done their degrees none of his kids is
gonna take over so when he goes his
whole thing of this whole thing goes
what do you do about that because it
seems like if you're if you're a hawker
and you do well you want your kids to
not be hawkers and understand those well
fortunately there are a breed of newer
younger hawkers who will say hey if he
goes that's a boy yeah young upstarts
like Kai who gave up a sales job to open
this roast paradise pork stall off old
Airport Road I know your customers are
happy but do you think you're happier
doing this then you where your sales job
at ten dollars a plate it's the most
expensive Hawker dish we tasted but also
one of the best but for Singaporeans to
keep coming here
Lillian Stefan say a younger new
generation of hawkers will be keep and
although they appreciate the
international acclaim Hawker centers
will disappear unless they continue to
give this island of fanatical foodies
exactly what they're after
exceptionally crafted food at an
unbelievable price this is something
that we're all passionate about it
divides us by at its impact unites all
of us I wanted to agree with him but my
mouth was full for CBS this morning
Saturday
Christina Ruffini Singapore go Chris
practicing what amazing food a shame to
lose culture would we we should all go
yes I'm ready
let's go just to check it out